so here's some hashtag not legal advice  for people that are engaging in tons and  tons of criminality  if someone asks you to write down a list  of all of the crimes that you have  committed  even if you're trying to get a pardon  maybe don't write those down but that  advice is apparently too late for joel  greenberg who apparently asked roger  stone  to get a pardon for him from former  president donald trump and in the  process of doing so  he wrote down all of the crimes that he  and his friend  congressman matt gates had engaged in  that would  obviously require a pardon from the  president so yeah here's the thing  don't do that ever do not ever write  down  all the crimes that you have done even  if you're seeking a pardon but  you know not legal advice so we'll  probably see that guy  in court